j'aime pourquoi vous m'appelez tous les
jours vous aussi vous recevez des appels
tous les jours de de cpf chez peak oil &
gas
[Musique]
par nos droits cpf on les perd jamais et
il n'y a pas d'agent du cpf officielle
qui vous appelle ça n'existe pas le cpf
c'est le compte personnel de formation
c'est un compte en euros que nous vous
ne pouvez pas retirer et qui permet
d'acheter des formations chaque année
quand on travaille on cotise des droits
cpf qui sont cumulables et après on peut
aller sur le site mon compte formation
pour voilà prendre une formation qui
nous intéresse excusez moi vous êtes
lully siens 50e qui m'appellent pour me
parler de mon compte personnel de
formation on essaie de catégoriser nous
déjà un peu bas ce qui se passe quand on
reçoit un appel et surtout qui sont les
gens derrière globalement donc il ya
plusieurs possibilités ça peut être une
façon de prendre vos identifiants pour
aller vider votre compte directement en
vous inscrivant une formation dont vous
verrez jamais la couleur parfois ça va
être de vous forcer la main à prendre
une formation qui parle forcément de
très bonne qualité vous allez être un
petit peu déçue et vous aurez un très
beau powerpoint à la fin en général ils
ont tous les mêmes formations
c'est-à-dire informatique bureautique
langues création d'entreprise si vous
entendez parler de ça c'est pas très bon
signe nous ce qu'on a trouvé c'était des
organismes de formation qui revendait
des formations qui étaient genre à 30,40
euros sur internet et qui avait dû faire
un deal avec les créateurs de la
formation pour avoir le droit de la
revendre sauf que entre l'information à
30 euros et celle à 1500 il y avait
juste un qcm de différence est un acquis
de compétences à la fin qui permettait
d'avoir une petite petite validation de
ce qu'on a appris mais le contenu est
elle-même n'est pas de l'arnaqué
factuellement c'est une très belle
revente leur but c'est globalement de
vous faire dépenser cet argent là qui
dort en général et il ya beaucoup
d'argent du cpf qui dort c'est que ce
n'est pas de votre faute je sais que
vous faites partie d'un système voilà je
peux pas m'empêcher de voir le comte cpf
il intéresse beaucoup de monde les
arnaqueurs et pas que parce qu'en fait
globalement toutes les toute personne
ayant travaillé en france un conte cpf
obligatoire qui pas forcément ouverts et
utilisés mais qui existe il ya environ
1500 euros par contre il ya environ 38
millions de comptes jusqu'à 30 millions
de personnes qui ont travaillé en france
ces dernières années et ça représente
pas loin de 60 milliards d'euros comme
marcher donc forcément
tire pas mal de monde parce que le
marché très juteux
[Musique]
l'immense majorité des formations sur
mon compte formation sont de qualité ne
présente pas de difficultés le risque
zéro ça n'existe pas je ne peux pas vous
garantir que sur les 900 milles session
de formation qui est dans laquelle nous
n'oublions catalogue il y en a pas
quelques unes qui qui posent difficulté
la première personne qui est porte une
responsabilité dans la régulation c'est
celui qui achète et donc c'est
extrêmement important que chacun avant
de s'inscrire à une formation
regarde comparé vérifie ni ensuite
la régulation elle est portée par le
ministère du travail par le ministère
des comptes publics un comité de
pilotage de lutte contre la fraude la
caisse des dépôts effectue aussi des
contrôles qualité sur les actions de
formation ça nous arrive de déréférencer
de sanctionner des organismes de
formation qui ne respectent pas les
conditions générales d'utilisation pour
vous donner des chiffres sur la fraude
on a fait un dépôt des dépôts de
plaintes pour environ 40 organismes de
formation
[Musique]
il faut fermer les vannes il ya trop
d'organismes de formation il faut trier
et ça c'est plutôt du côté de la caisse
des dépôts on peut pas demander aux
utilisateurs d'être vigilant sur des
choses qui connaissent pas quand vous
allez vouloir prendre une formation afin
l'édition site officiel mon compte
formation point.fr qui très simple pour
commander mais si pour rechercher une
formation c'est impossible c'est à dire
que vous allez mettre une catégorie vous
allez avoir huit résultats par lui
résultats sur des centaines de milliers
de formation il ya juste un petit
classement avec des étoiles qui peut
être bidonné assez facilement ce qu'il
faut c'est trier beaucoup plus à
l'entrée trier ce qui est déjà rentré du
côté de la caisse des dépôts et surtout
améliorer le site parce que là en fait
on sait pas ce qu'on achète directement
c'est vrai qu'on entend beaucoup le cpf
parce que démarchage téléphonique parce
que arnaque etc mais ce qu'il faut se
dire c'est que c'est bien un bel outil
pour se former parce qu'en fait vous
avez droit chaque année des centaines
d'euros qui sont cumulés et sur lequel
vous pouvez voilà utiliser ça pour vous
reconvertir pour approfondir des
connaissances en passant par de vrais
organismes qualifiés vous avez un vrai
truc sympa et vous pouvez vraiment
évoluer dans votre apprentissage c'est
pas que les arnaques c'est pas que le
démarchage téléphonique chiant ça reste
quand même un ancien système qui a été
mis à jour de façon assez efficace pour
pouvoir se former